faker is suing individuals who have left
him and others hateful comments online
it takes a lot to rattle the league of
legends goat and clearly what's been
said has pushed him to his absolute
limit this isn't the first time we've
seen this kind of abuse directed towards
players in korea so let's unpack the
whole situation
[Music]
faker he's known for being the greatest
player to ever touch league of legends
some people thought he was reaching the
twilight of his career and then earlier
this year with the help of his t1
teammates he showed why you'd be mad to
ever count him out an absolutely
historical moment 18-0 for the first
time in the lck and they tie 2015 summer
skt and don juan 2020 summer two teams
that they went on to win worlds at plus
29 points in the season unprecedented
he's also known for just being a
generally nice guy quiet at times but
someone who knows how to have fun he's
not just loved because of his skills but
also because of who he is hitoki
yeah yeah i think he's officially
you
i'm a free yes secretary okay
yeah maybe this year 2020 yeah so you
might think nobody could be mean to this
guy he's an ambassador for the game and
a shining example of when talent meets
humility but unfortunately you'd be
wrong on july 19th faker's legal team
apex law spoke to press in south korea
to announce they had filed a lawsuit
against those who have written malicious
comments against faker online invent
global's daniel kwan published an
article which included the statement as
translated by inven it read despite t1's
repeated request towards those that
leave malicious comments we found that
not only were there more of these
comments but they also have gotten more
malicious the player the player's family
and all those around him continue to
suffer on a mental level so we had no
choice but to file a criminal lawsuit
against those that left such spiteful
online comments with respect to faker's
opinion on this matter we are filing
criminal lawsuits only towards those
that repeatedly and habitually left such
malicious comments as he felt that these
individuals need to be severely
sanctioned as such there will be no plea
nor favorable arrangement deals please
be aware that our law firm will continue
to monitor online comments to see if
there are such spiteful comments that
can be criminally implicated towards
faker and the t1 players and will
proactively take legal action to combat
such harassment we hope that a healthy
and a mature esports culture can be
established to avoid such legal action
in the future in the following q a
section they stated they would be suing
a small group of people that made a
large chunk of the comments when asked
for details of the comments reporters
were told they were slanders towards
faker's mother and drawings that could
be considered quote unspeakably foul
they said that similar lawsuits
involving south korea's insult laws have
seen fines between one and two million
korean won that's roughly 764 to
1529 us dollars but that depending on
the severity and the frequency of the
insults the accused may be subject to
jail time as mentioned by ashley kang on
twitter the lawsuit is being filed under
south korea's criminal act article 311
which states that publicly insulting
another shall be punished by
imprisonment or imprisonment without
prison labor for up to a year or by a
fine of up to two million won which
again is roughly 1529
us dollars it's also noteworthy that the
harassment faker receive goes beyond the
usual gameplay critique from disgruntled
fans the slanders and drawings he's
received seem personal and we can only
guess what unspeakably foul means pretty
heavy stuff all round now unless you
keep up to date with korean league of
legends this might seem like it's come
out of absolutely nowhere but it hasn't
back in the summer 2020 split t1 failed
to qualify for worlds for only the
second time in the orgs history after
being eliminated from the playoffs and
then the regional gauntlet now this was
a shock to any league fan t1 were and
still are the most successful org in the
history of the game with three world
titles and two msi titles to their name
back in their home country of south
korea the shock tipped over into anger
and abuse from some so-called t1 fans a
month earlier t1 ceo joe marsh had
announced they could no longer remain
silent about the rise in online
harassment and violent threats of t1
players he said they were exploring the
options of legal action after t1 were
eliminated from playoffs they confirmed
they were preparing for such action
adding that it wasn't just the players
but their families too that had been
threatened it was also around this time
that tijuan's former ad carry teddy said
in an interview that faker is the one
who gets targeted the most by this kind
of harassment a few months later there
was an incident in which some t1 fans
circled around the headquarters of skt
the parent company of t1 to protest
among other things the potential hiring
of new team management the message board
on their truck lambasted t1 for hiring
famed league coach and personality ls
who they described as a coach who would
cause public controversy ls ended up
temporarily deleting his twitter and his
friend nemesis explained on stream just
how bad the abuse had gotten no i was in
a call with alice um
he's in a really bad spot
apparently he's
now his grandmother is being harassed
and stuff like this and people are
trying to
do
really bad things to him some fans even
sent funeral wreaths to the t1
headquarters to mark what they saw as
the death of the org they once knew the
point is faker filing this lawsuit is
really just the latest chapter in a
battle against abuse that he and t1 have
been facing for years and it's not just
limited to t1 of course a day before the
faker lawsuit announcement katie rolster
another legendary korean team shared
some extremely disturbing news their
statement translated by horizon esports
kevin kim said that on top of the team
receiving hate and abuse they had also
been sent photographs of deadly weapons
and was center box containing a real
deadly weapon to their training facility
the statement also reportedly said that
katie rolster believes this behavior
falls under south korean laws relating
to insults and special intimidation look
esports is massive in korea many of you
watching this will know that it's always
been a bastion of skill and excellence
especially in league of legends and as
such their players are held to high
standards that seem extremely foreign to
esports fans from other countries of
course that is no excuse for the
behavior we've talked about in this
video but it's at least a basic starting
point for beginning to wrap your head
around it and it's not limited to
esports either in the k-pop world there
have been similar lawsuits filed against
fans who harassed the stars in 2019
k-pop star sully was found dead in her
apartment her death was ruled a suicide
a number of fans felt that critical
comments online had affected her mental
health this prompted calls for the
creation of a so-called sully's law
which would seek to combat anonymous
cyber bullying by forcing people to use
their real identities online it's
important to remember that online toxic
cultures exist all over the world but at
least in the world of korean esports and
kpop this particular type of toxicity
does seem to be on the rise will faker's
lawsuit stop him from being on the
receiving end of it we can hope but who
knows south korean laws do seem to
empower victims to pursue this course of
action more than other places in the
world but if anything this is also about
sending a message to the toxic fans who
harass players like faker they're going
to make the harassers lives as difficult
as possible and hope that others learn
from their mistakes
[Music]
you